after Paris a new danger realized
homegrown terrorism coupled with a
genuine threat across member states so
does Europe have a role to play the
chair the civil liberties committee yes
the issue is cross-border and
anti-terrorism legislation coupled with
anti radicalization measures could help
strengthen measures already in place
safety of citizens is the paramount
thing but what terrorists want us to do
is to abandon our freedoms and it's very
important always to get a balance of a
delicate balance between essential
security of our citizens on the one hand
but to ensure at the same time that we
preserve our fundamental freedoms
passenger name record the collection of
traveler information once seen as
controversial and rejected by any piece
is now likely to pass through Parliament
no service de jose more so kappab do
detective aquino part so sandy pox on da
suke evil Pacquiao Syrian Air Act in
Otranto so a facility Cassano turkey at
a certain way and cgz lupini meetings
like this will continue in the months
ahead as Europe cobbles together to try
to find the right response